in 2018 something happened that
shattered every truism Hollywood has
held dear for the past ever black
panther a story set in africa with a
mostly black cast became the highest
grossing domestic film of the year
beating even Avengers infinity war take
that Bannos and while many people may
have heard the term afrofuturism before
black panther took the world by storm
suddenly it solidified afrofuturism
entry into the mainstream but while
black panther is a milestone for
afrofuturism it certainly isn't the sum
total of the genre later the same year
Tommy Eddie Emmys children of blood and
bone topped the New York Times
bestseller list and Janelle Monae who's
been dabbling in the genre both
musically and aesthetically for over a
decade released their third album dirty
computer I got the t-shirt it's an
amazing album please listen to it but
echo futurism doesn't just mean science
fiction plus Africa it's a bit more
nuanced than that afrofuturism addresses
the cultural issues and concerns of the
African Diaspora so you type in a
culture and science fiction which is
what Black Panther does but you can't
just wrap a lightsaber in Kente cloth
and call it afrofuturism unless you're a
John Bull yet he can do it after
futurism like rap reggae jazz blues and
all the music that has come out of the
black experience is about creating art
out of pain strength loss and successes
it is fundamentally rooted and being
denied a full history and looking to the
future to correct that in his 1994 essay
black to the future
author and lecturer Mark Derry asks can
a community whose past has been
deliberately rubbed out and whose
energies have subsequently been consumed
by the search for legible traces of its
history imagined possible futures and
this is where afrofuturism cousins
at the root of afrofuturism is black
speculative fiction which uses science
fiction as a way of telling stories
about black resistance history and hope
economists sociologists Alondra Nelson
who convene an early online forum of
afrofuturism quotes afrofuturism has
emerged as a term of convenience to
describe analysis criticism and cultural
production that addresses the
intersection between race and technology
one of the resilience of black culture
and black life is about imagining the
impossible imagining a better place a
different world afrofuturism draws upon
the feeling of alienation inherited from
the slavery of American blacks which it
sublimates
in this conception certain elements of
afro-american culture such as a
transcendence of spirituals are
reimagined and transposed into a new
cosmic and legendary perspective where
the alienated becomes extraterrestrial
in an essay written by NK jemisin from
2013 titled how long till black future
month which later became the talent for
2018 short story collection she
discusses watching the old hanna-barbera
cartoon The Jetsons and being struck at
how homogenious the series depiction of
an idyllic future is with no people of
color in it a clarinha Jemison quote
there is no body even slightly Brown in
the Jetsons world even the family
Android sounds white this is supposed to
be the real world's future right abia in
a silly humorous form thing is not white
people make up most of the world's
population now as well as back in the
60s when the show was created so what
happened to all those people in the
minds of this show's creator are they
beneath the clouds where the Jetsons
never go was there our apocalypse or
maybe a pogrom
although the mainstream efficacious of
afrofuturism is relatively new its
themes have appeared in literature for
over a century in 1899 Charles W
chestnut published a collection of short
stories called the Condor woman which
discussed themes of black resistance and
revenge against Antebellum culture using
traditional african-american
spirituality
in 1902 of one blood was published
serially by Pauline Hopkins which talks
about a man who does an expedition to
Ethiopia and discovers a hidden
technologically advanced civilization
it's basically what Conda before Wakonda
the novel also explores the protagonists
own anti-blackness and ignorance towards
black history he goes to Ethiopia to
find treasure but instead finds his own
form of black identities in the 1920s
WTB Dubois wrote among the first
post-apocalyptic short fiction with
black subjects called the comet in the
story Dubois writes about a black man
named Jim Davis the only man left alive
after a comet hits New York City and
unleashes toxic gases that kill everyone
except himself and a white woman named
Julia Jim rises as a symbol of the
savior and hero of the narrative a new
atom in this destroyed New York in the
book afrofuturism the world of black
sci-fi and fantasy culture Natasha
L Romek a leading afro-futurist explains
that the story is one of the first to
portray that blackness is not a mark of
shame but a source of pride establishing
a space where black culture can thrive
no conversation about afrofuturism would
be complete without Octavia Butler
wildly considered the grand Dom of
sci-fi today I call her the goat
personally starting with the release of
her first book patterned master in 1976
Butler went on to release a dozen
science fiction novels featuring
afro-futurist themes while she wasn't as
appreciated in her time renewed interest
in afrofuturism has led to a surge of
new readers of her work her books are
now often included in many high school
and college required reading lists that
Butler is only recently getting her do
reflects how slow the mainstream has
been to take interest in black fiction
but hey we're getting there noted modern
works that fall under the afro-futurist
umbrella include Nettie Acorah force who
fears death and binti
50 is a novella about a girl that
overcomes humble beginnings as offered a
place at
Iza University one of the most
prestigious institutions of higher
learning and the galaxy but a great deal
of this series focuses on binti trying
to
reconcile her heritage with her own
natural intelligence at personal goals
and unkindness of ghost by River Solomon
who was a Campbell Award nominee for
best new writer in 2018 explores how
sustained acts of abuse and violence can
shape a culture and people this one
takes place on a generation ship that is
not only stratified based on race but
also extremely restrictive of any
nonconformity especially with regard to
gender it is effectively coping with the
violence of colonialism in space
afro-futurist storytellers take
advantage of the speculative nature of
the genre by simultaneously creating new
worlds and deconstructing the racial
politics of this one one of the
criticisms lodged against dystopian
fiction like market outwards to
Handmaid's Tale or suzanne collins the
hollow games trilogy is that even in the
worst of futures there's no place for
black bodies because either they were
banished or just seemed to disappear
this is why it's important to recognize
the thematic elements of afrofuturism
that go beyond the idea that a crow
features images science fiction plus
africa afrofuturism is about reclaiming
our past in order to craft our future
and that is done by infusing black sound
and stories with flora thinking desire
to see how our culture could have
evolved or could still evolve unhindered
by colonial influence here's how authors
and Steve Jemison put it as part of a
panel in 2016 quote I think we're the
most radical things that anyone in this
world can do is imagine that black
people have a future through
afrofuturism black society has a future
that is beyond the clouds just like
everyone else one final question we
should ask is afrofuturism too broad a
turn
some African authors like okorafor
reject the title of afrofuturism because
they do not write through the
perspective of Western blackness
okorafor is a nigerian american who is
deeply connected to african culture and
she explains in her TED talk how she
writes science fiction through that lens
quote I can best explain the difference
between classic science fiction and
afrofuturism if I use the octopus
analogy like humans octopuses are some
of the most intelligent creatures on
earth
however octopus intelligence evolved
from a different evolutionary line so
the foundation
is different the same can be said about
the foundations of various forms of
science fiction and non-western culture
the mystical coexisting with the mundane
is normal a core for also points to the
history of afrofuturism being associated
with music especially in the United
States with African artists as an
afterthought in short I understand the
necessity of it I understand the use of
it but I do not consider myself an afro
futurist as we enter a post black
panther era afrofuturism is not just a
cultural aesthetic philosophy of science
and philosophy of history but also a
money-making machine
Disney Marvel and Ryan Coogler turned
the story of the first black comic book
superhero into a film that became the
twelfth highest-grossing film of all
time with over 1.35 billion worldwide
Cooke learns with the story and infused
it with the kind of narrative that is at
the heart of afrofuturism the
possibility that Africa and its
descendants could have a powerful
present and future and made it immensely
entertaining and marketable it will
genuinely be exciting to see
afrofuturism grow and expand as more
black authors tackle the questions claim
the aesthetic and build upon its core
idea that not only do black people
across the world have a future but it's
going to be pretty darn lip because we
cool it for ourselves
[Music]